[Music]
[Music]
hey hey hey hey how you livin how you
feel how you doing how you feeling
Warren sharp is in the building today
how you feelin man nice blazer good
texture
it's like a heathered blue so it pops
but it's got a little bit of the dots to
it it works with my my JS let me see the
fives some royal blue fives the pre
great pre grape yeah I always love when
you're here it makes the conversation
that much better and a little birdie
tells me you're gonna be here for the
next two weeks so we had two weeks on
the road two weeks here also a little
birdie tells me that the models are
firing right now firing are you hit like
explain explain to the 33% what this
time of the year is like for somebody
that pours years into analytics and why
it starts hitting its gear right now
they're there becomes like just the
sweet spot where the numbers I get I
have enough data and I'm processing it
in a slightly different way than the
oddsmakers are I mean that's the only
way that I would have an edge after year
after year is that I'm looking at things
a little bit differently than they do
and so my model is a little bit
different I'm factoring in some other
things right and I'm constantly evolving
and growing and building and and would
you say this is the point of the year
where even if there's other big betting
groups or there's other big sharps out
there and they move in a way that's
different than you your models are at a
point where instead of maybe earlier in
the year where you get a little bit
nervous now you're kind of looking at
and going thank you for the value yes
you're that much more confident in your
models right there's there's a game this
week where
I feel I know that I know the group is
that is opposite me I have not gone yet
because I saw them come on one side of
this store and I am actually happy that
they did you know a lot of people will
be like oh I don't want to go up against
them you know like I I really respect
them but right me I know what my model
has done over the last 13 years I know
what it's doing so far in the 14th year
and I feel very confident and putting
that up against anybody whether it's a
bookmaker or another betting syndicate
and what's really cool is we've talked
about your website a lot sharp football
analysis calm I didn't know you'd do
this
so apparently every year one week
everything is free yeah you're a psycho
and we appreciate you I just try to give
people like pull back the curtain let
you see what I do
when Isis the week this is the week
right so if you go to sharp football
analysis I think you were telling me
before some pop ups will pop up that say
hey check it out right now you can go on
there you can read some of the articles
that are on there you can see is it
rebar rebar rebar rich rebar he has a
lot of fantasy nuggets I use that when
I'm making my line up so I'm scouring
the waiver wire but also on your website
if you sign up you'll get the email
alerts and then I have those set up on
Sundays because sometimes you have those
late pushes or maybe a Saturday
afternoon where I'll get that email
that'll say heads up Warren's about to
put out a pic in 15 minutes and then I
go to your website I think your website
it's great there's a little countdown on
it like new pic coming in two minutes
and this week we've told people before
about the codes and all that this week
you get to see it for free yeah you
don't need any code this week just go to
the site you'll see a banner on the top
of the website it'll show you how you
can get on board for free we do send the
emails and the reason why I do the
countdown and all that is because my
valuation timelines right my
recommendations move line so I want all
of all the clients to get the same
number that I'm putting out this
happened with I think it was Houston
Oakland you put it out the over at fifty
and a half it moved to fifty one and a
half and the total was 51 right so you
had to get in that early window in order
to get it and the people that go to your
website can so just
all the 33% all the homies out there
this week on sharp football analysis it
is all free so go sign up get the emails
if you want to bet bet responsibly at
the same point try it out and hopefully
if I can read the fantasy yes nation
there's a preview and breakdown of every
single game it's already published out
on the website you can find that in your
dashboard and he does a really good job
breaking those games down plus we do
some props nobody works harder than
Warren and so that's part of the reason
we have him here is because he works
with us and it's [ __ ] dope all right
so we're gonna get two sharps cool we're
gonna get two EDS are we're gonna get to
the scheduling advantage and look at
some of the biggest games the week and
of course they're all at the four
o'clock and Monday Night Football wanna
I mean this has so many implications to
playoff seedings to that division you
know if the Seahawks lose and the Rams
win holy crap Seahawks Niners is gonna
be great so and it's it's Kyle Shanahan
versus Pete Carroll which is always a
blast but there was one thing that you
talked a little bit about of your
website that caught our attention when
we talked last night which was halftime
leads it's this thing that it doesn't
seem important until you look at the
numbers and you found that teams that
are leading at halftime this year are
winning what percentage of their games
eighty percent roughly eighty percent so
the teams that are up at a halftime if
you're watching a game four out of five
times that team is winning the game
outright yep absolutely is that
surprising to you or what does it say to
you that teams need to realize well it's
surprising to me from the context that I
don't hear anybody else talking about it
and I don't hear enough team's game
planning to build for to build a first
half game plan that is geared towards
having that lead at halftime I see an in
here because I work with a lot of these
teams yeah guys that are talking about
let's just try to have a good game plan
or let's just try to stay close you know
they're an underdog let's just try to
stay close but not many of them actually
say let's figure out how we're going to
between our scripting and our
aggressiveness and our play calling
frequent sure maybe I'd be more
aggressive in the first half
to build that lead and then you went
back and said okay hopefully this isn't
just a one year thing you looked at the
last five and the percentage was right
around the same again yeah close to 80
percent over the last five years is this
just because teams the better teams are
the favorites and they kind of go out
there and build Ally like kind of just
be subscribed to that so that's
initially my first take right I'm
looking at okay well maybe there's like
ten point favorites you know nine point
favorites they're the better teams they
should win these games so they've got a
lead so of course they're gonna they're
gonna have a good shot at winning the
games but I went back and looked at
underdogs any underdog of any size if
they've got a halftime lead they're
winning 66% of these games outright like
for covering the spread they're covering
it like 80 to 83 percent against the
spread if those dogs have a lead at
halftime they're still winning 66
percent of the time outright so this is
maybe I don't know how I would use this
from the betting perspective it sounds
like a note you would give to coaches
though that are like hey that
flea-flicker you're planning to save for
the second half or that really
screenplay that you know maybe not save
it maybe use it right away to build that
lead because I feel like it gets into
the psyche of the opposing coach where
they adjust their their plays at
halftime because they have a deficit
100% the opposing teams are going to sit
there in the locker room trailing and
say to themselves what do we need to
call differently to draw even and then
win this game so we've got to scrap some
of the stuff we were planning on doing
or we like doing in the first half
because we got to get more aggressive
we've got to be more risky and with risk
comes reward but there also comes that
things are not necessarily optimal
towards your this game you're gonna be
doing things that are a little bit more
outside your comfort zone yeah that
could end up backfiring and so you don't
want to be that team that's in the
locker room scratching your head
thinking okay what are we going to do
differently this second half because
we're down you want to be the team
that's leading at halftime that says
okay here's what worked let's try to do
a couple more things build off of some
of that let's make a play that looks
like that but do something differently
and and we're gonna have
continue to establish this lead-in and
have success have you said that the
teams this week yeah this information
how do they react to it some some for
some of them again it's it's kind of new
for someone can you tell when you're
talking to a coach or somebody on staff
when a light bulb goes off in their head
it's obviously easier to do that when
you're actually seeing them in person
right or so like in the offseason I'm
able to meet with some of these guys in
person over the phone it's less easy to
do that so some of the some of the guys
might you here just pauses you know
where they're kind of like processing
and they're like oh that's that's
interesting that's interesting you know
because my fear about this statistic is
is it I didn't want it to be like the
when you run the ball 25 times you're 36
and 3 you know what I mean I didn't want
to be one of those we'll just get a
first half lead you don't have to worry
about the second half but it really does
get into the psyche of it and when you
look at the teams this year at first
half deficits and how they fared it's
wild I have the list right here
the Patriots when losing at halftime
this year oh and one the Ravens
oh and two the Chiefs oh and two the
Cowboys Oh in three the Vikings oh and
two the Panthers oh and three I mean
that is right there
three six ten that's Owen 13 and all of
those teams are in the playoff race
right now
these are playoff teams that when losing
at halftime have gone on to lose every
single game they've played this year and
you went back and looked at the last
five years to make sure it's not a fluke
and it's the same thing it's the same
thing now they don't they don't lose
every single game right percentages are
even the Patriots even the Patriots
struggled now again naturally some of
this is like okay we're down a team
that's down by 10 points through some
errors is going to have a tough time
winning this game of course we have to
account for some obvious logic in this
but at the same time it just goes to
show you that some of the best coaches
the best play callers the best players
on the field the best comprised rosters
still find it difficult to come back so
imagine what the bad teams are I mean
look at the Cowboys for example over the
last five years they are four and 18 in
their 22
four wins out of 22 when they've trailed
at halftime like they are a team that's
built on we got to try to get this lead
and then we can use our run game and do
everything that we love to do insult it
away in the second half but when they
don't have that lead they have to go
outside the box of what's comfortable to
them and so I asked you okay who are
three teams this year that have been
losing at halftime but are actually
winning more than they lose who are the
coaches that have been able to turn it
around and the three teams that you
found this year were the Texans at three
into this season the Seahawks at four
and one which is wild and the Niners
that are 2a know and you look back and
you look to the last three years under
Kyle Shannon the Niners are three and 14
with a deficit so still right on par the
Texans what was the Texans the last five
years in development you looked at I'll
talk about the Seahawks the Seahawks the
last three years this is definitely
about Russell Wilson the last three
years when losing at halftime the
Seahawks are 10 and 13 the Patriots are
5 and 13 the Seahawks are 10 and 13 is
can I just say that's all Russell Wilson
is that fair it's mostly fair the
Seahawks have been for years under Pete
Carroll a very conservative team right
that tends to want to start games by
running the football and they don't
really want to put too much on Russell
shoulders for so long they were a team
even even when they weren't paying rust
they had better players in the other
position right they were team we've got
a good defense we've got a good run game
let's marry these two up and not really
over expose our ability to give the ball
to Mike Davis 18 times right exactly but
what we're seeing now is the fact that
when they start trailing and they have
to pass the ball that's actually not a
bad thing because Russ is damn good when
when you're blitzing he's so good under
pressure he's the best quarterback in
the NFL right now when you're blitzing
he's averaging nine yards per attempt
when he's under pressure right the guy
is so good at eluding pressure whereas I
think what would her two people I mean
he's my best in the end of people are
like seven and a half seven and he's
like
yard event the average quarterback right
now in terms of passer rating in the
league when they're under pressure is
right in like the 60 to 70 range in
terms of passer rating
Russell Wilson I think is like a 119 I
said earlier this week that Tyler
Lockett Russell Wilson's the the best
quarterback wide receiver combo in the
sport how do you feel about my hot take
I mean no doubt Russ is there and he's
bringing Lockett with him like the cool
thing about those guys yeah is they just
have this uncanny like they're connected
at the hip like 30 yards down the field
like I know what the other one wants to
do and that's my thing is I'm not
talking about you know Mike Evans is
more impressive if you put him on any
roster in the NFL he's gonna be Mike
Evans Tyler Lockett might not be that
way but I've never seen this connection
between two humans that Russ's balls
land so perfectly and lock its ability
to use every single angle of his
wingspan and like it I've just never
seen a connection like this before
it's is really cool because Lockett is
not the prototypical wr1
right oh he's he's skinny he's short but
he's quick and and Russ though had that
connection with Doug Baldwin it was sort
of similar not quite as quick as as as
Lockett but it's just about I don't know
the the practice that they must put in
on their own has to be phenomenal
because these guys know what the other
one wants to do they're reading from the
same sheet of music that the only the
two of them seemed to have and it's
beautiful to watch it work out I was
surprised by the Texans as being one of
those teams that was losing the first
half is actually doing better because in
your book before the year what were they
won in 18 the last two years yes with a
deficit and so the fact that they're
three and two this year can I say this
is all deshaun Watson again or is that
insulting Bill O'Brien I think most of
it is DeSean why he's a special player
as well same type of guy a guy who's
going to get pressured but can elude
that whether he runs that's the other
thing about quarterbacks that have the
ability to run the football is they can
make positives happen whereas like
pocket pure pocket
like this is a problem with Baker right
now you know Baker when he gets
pressured he either
throws it out of bounds or throws an
incompletion sometimes an interception
Turtles up like he's not as often like
what Russ is doing scrambling to throw
and scrambling to run if he needs to you
know and the more dangerous element is
scrambling to throw because the defense
is really compromised when you're out of
the pocket and you have to try to cover
that wide receiver as a cornerback for
four seconds five seconds it's
ridiculous how far open that guy has the
potential of getting then and you're not
able to cover them but if that does get
covered of course Russ can run the
football there is no more helpless of a
person than a linebacker with Russell
Wilson running at him with a running
back next to him Russell Wilson's
ability to draw the linebacker and at
the last second do like a basketball
alley-oop to a third string tight end or
a second string running back who then
turns it into a 40 yard gain I mean that
to me is one of the that to me is the
Russell Wilson play in addition to the
spin and he throws it in the perfect
corner of the endzone
the Russell Wilson play is the run at a
linebacker and then the quick dump pass
to like a Luke Wilson who goes for 40
yards and then that at stadiums is
yelling Luke for two minutes that's
Russell Wilson and I've actually seen
that a little bit more this year not
with Russ not just with rust but some
other quarterbacks where that is the
move typically the move is I want to
avoid this linebacker because I don't
want him to hear right that's typically
the move like let me run away from him
but what some of these guys are starting
to do is run at the guy force him to
commit to use like the pure read option
force him to commit to you yes and then
you do though you do the glass I think
us what he's probably gonna barely touch
you and then there's 15 yards added on
to the 40 yard play because we protect
the quarterback exactly the other side
teams that have a first half lead but
lose more than they win this happens
this I I remember two years ago with the
Colts with Jacoby percent they were
going into the fourth quarter
leading nine to the 16 and still found
ways to lose but this year teams with a
first half lead that are losing more
than they win
who are these teams that have been
disappointing their fans thus far it's
it's everybody that you would expect
okay with one additional guy who I think
after this week we'll ring a bell to
everybody as well the Bengals and the
Dolphins obviously two terrible teams
sometimes they do happen to get a lead
right then they're leading over the
Seahawks I think in week one
okay and the Dolphins had some leads and
they and they blew right as well they're
up they weren't up on the Patriots but
they were up on Steelers yeah you're up
on the Steelers enuf I know that there
is I think there was one other game for
them and then the Box that's the third
one with Jameis and I'm sorry but you
know that's that looked so good like
that with that that is two games that
you picked that you said EDS ours
looking really interesting bucks over
Seahawks and it looked genius all week
it looked to use all game and Raiders
over lions which was beautiful and came
true and I I told you on the phone last
night that I I can't do this anymore
like I can't just like a few weeks ago I
was like I can't bet against the Saints
anymore it's just I know that the the
models are saying it betting on Jameis
when he commits these self committed
fumbles it's it's tragic and I know
you're probably gonna tell me later in
the show that the Bucs have an advantage
but like I can't do it anymore Warren I
you miss it's it's and that's a call
that you make as a better with your
heart in your pocketbook and what stress
you want to put yourself through this
also speaks to the importance of getting
the best number possible right now I
will tell you that last Monday last
Monday yeah you put it on your site i we
took it we bet it gave it to clients you
even said to bet it up to seven yeah it
was six and a half and I said bye to the
seven normally we're on key numbers we
might do that oftentimes if it's like
other numbers we're not going to
necessarily buy the half point but in
this case it was six and a half
I knew this line was gonna drop it was
down to like four four and a half it's a
lot of spots by close so that's massive
line value that means that you're on the
right side of this bet okay
of course they have a big lead they're
leading this game early they're leading
at halftime
yeah and they have a chance to win or at
worst lose by three at the end of
regulation and you're gonna cover your
bet I know that of course goes to
overtime I was disappointed even though
I won on seven I was disappointed number
one with the money line aspect number
two for some contest I had five and a
half so I I buy them losing by six I
lost those wagers in the contest oh I
just that they're the perfect team for
the first half lead but lose because
they have a quarterback that doesn't
know how to protect the lead that and
their defense stinks and pass defense is
terrible so it was a perfect storm it
was like oh you get Russell Wilson
getting unleashed in the second half and
also you know what props to the Seahawks
for finally throwing now back-to-back
weeks a lot more than they've been
running is this something that you think
we can kind of think that Schottenheimer
is gonna continue the rest of the way
against teams with good run defenses I
hope he continues as I tweeted out
yesterday a picture from the sharp
football stats website which showed the
fact that the last two teams that they
played both had top-10 run defenses and
in the first quarter on first downs he
went like 67 percent pass or more Wow so
he was much more password which is
something he had only done one other
time on the season so you know a lot of
teams look the Detroit lines did the
same thing I was calling those guys out
repeatedly on Twitter because I had
watched them those teams with good run
defenses and this is when the Raiders
have a good run defense Raiders have a
very good run defense a very terrible
past defend every term and you want to
be throwing the football on these guys
but you have a coach like a true Harrell
or a Matt Patricia for the inline skater
a variable or my kraebel who are
conservative their style of zevran Mike
Zimmer and they want to start
establishing the run and run the
football often and when in fact against
those types of Defense's you need to be
coming out and passing the football
early and Detroit definitely did it and
they got themselves a nice early lead
they were they were playing very well in
that game yeah and we obviously saw the
Seahawks even though they trailed again
the bucks they came out passing just
like they did against Atlanta that we
talked about this in weeks two or three
where you're sort of you're not sure if
coaches are gonna do the right thing
yeah and and so when they do the right
thing it gives you a lot more confidence
betting on the rest of the way correct
yeah you never know when they could
regress like in the game against the
Atlanta Falcons right there could have
been one of two things happening there
the reason why they went much more
run-heavy and a lot of lancet to pull
within seven the first thing is they
didn't I mean they were a big you know
you don't know what they're gonna say
you know embarrassed like Dan Quinn
right so we don't come running up the
score passing on him because he's our
old buddy the second element is like
well we're conservative by nature and so
we've got a lead let's just run and just
end this game and unfortunately in their
case like Atlanta is playing with a
backup quarterback Matt Schaub and
they're still like coming and scoring on
your defense because your defense is
pretty terrible that's the thing that
like I would impart upon Brian
Schottenheimer is you've got to stay
aggressive ya cannot get conservative
with a lead in the second how about
these are the same defense that you've
had before right that's I thought about
the Eagles and the Bears hey I know
you're playing Mitchell too risky I know
you have a two touchdown lead did we all
not watch the Falcons Patriots Super
Bowl it does not pay to get conservative
and say let's get out of here quicker
because it's gonna happen it's gonna be
two minutes left you get the [ __ ] out of
here because we're ruining this and when
you have to turn it on it doesn't turn
on well it's the same type of thing it's
it's it's different principle sorry it's
the same principle but a different
application and that was what we saw on
Monday Night Football where the Dallas
Cowboys were playing the Giants and what
did we see outta pat Shermer we saw a
very conservative approach kicking field
goals like okay well we'll cut it from
like what was it like a six point lead
to a three point lead or we cut it you
know all these small margins it's okay
to keep kick coming at twelve nine and
the thing that is frustrating to me is
that these coaches need to realize and I
don't know what you would call I call it
maybe like score board fallacy or
something like that where you're looking
at the scoreboard and you're saying okay
if I bring it down to this number then
if I get the ball back I'll be in good
shape but what you have to take into
account is that your own defense stinks
and the other teams going to get the
ball after you score
so they're possibly gonna go score on
you so when you have the opportunity to
get that close to the endzone like what
is the harm in trying to get that first
down so that you can try to score a
touchdown so that if the other team
actually goes down and score touchdown
right like you might be I'll still win
it with a field goal I always think to
when you have an offense that was
performing let's say like the Giants
offense was if you get down inside the
five or the ten and that's your first
time getting down there all game why are
you so confident that you're gonna be
able to do this again this might be your
only time that you get down there and
that's why I appreciated the Ravens
Patriots game so much to watch a Ravens
team that has now went into Kansas City
and said the only chance we have to win
this game is to go for all four point
all fourth down conversions and all
two-point conversions and they hung in a
game they had no reason to be in and
then the Patriots they go in there and
they're able to do the exact same
mentality and yet I'm watching Belichick
settle for field goals at the half and
that was what was so shocking but I I
applaud the Ravens for having the right
mentality it is okay to be in a game and
go this team scares me a little bit we
need to take our shots yeah and also
realize that the public is finally up to
I think accepting this and will not
question you for not getting a fourth
down on your own 40 like I think the
public has finally come around to going
if it's 4th and 1 on your own 40 and
we're down 6 with 5 minutes left it's ok
to go for it Bill Belichick loosened
this up about a decade ago by going for
fourth down on his own 25 against Peyton
Manning and the Colts because he knew if
I get the ball back we're screwed
and he was destroyed for it in 2006 or
whatever the hell that was but now I
just don't understand the people that
don't you're given a pass we accept it
now and I want to I want to I want to
congratulate the Ravens because they
played that game on Sunday perfectly
perfectly I mean they might have a
letdown against the Bengals afterwards
but they played that perfectly' in their
division there is one coach that has
come out and said not the biggest fan of
analytics not even that
he went further Freddie kitchens was
trying to defend Baker Mayfield talking
about completion percentage and all the
statistics and he said quote there's a
lot of factors that go into that I don't
think he's just wildly missing passes I
don't really look at that I truly do not
look at stats I went back and watched
the whole thing it is not taken out of
context he is talking about how he
doesn't really look at stats i've seen
other bloviator x' on TV talking about
anything that Freddie kitchens would
have said would have been bad he could
have said I watch I read all the stats i
watch all the film and we'd still kill
him I disagree
we are in a world now where analytics
and statistics in your own division
Freddie kitchens with mr. Harbaugh are
showing how you can play a 20-19 version
the NFL so I asked you warren sharp a
leader in the analytics community
someone that works with teams to provide
statistics that changes game plans and
thus can change ELLs to double use when
you hear Freddie kitchens say quote I
truly do not look at stats what do you
think at first I who definitely wanted
to give him the benefit of the doubt
because you never know what he's trying
to state particularly defend yeah I
thought that it had to do with the fact
that they were talking about what Baker
Mayfield is ranked on his completion
percentage so you thought maybe Freddy
kitchens was like I don't care if Baker
Mayfield is the 22nd best completion
percentage right and they said he's not
he's near the bottom of the league in
completion percentage and he said well I
don't look at that I don't care about
stats so I was assuming that maybe he
just was like taking I don't look at
that one step further say that he
doesn't look at stats but when I
actually watch his team play and I dig
through the numbers myself it is
apparent to me that something is not
right there because there are stats that
are showing this team is very very
efficient when they play a certain way
mmm
but there
majority of the time a way that's very
inefficient for them a way that Baker
Mayfield has not is not thriving in and
yet they don't seem to recognize their
problems with that style and I'm talking
about the difference between 12 and 11
yeah we would sign this this week one
I've been to yes last year when Freddie
kitchens came to Cleveland and took oh
he was there earlier but when he took
over from Hugh Jackson he did a few
different things with Baker he was using
him a little bit different under center
right he was using different personnel
groupings giving him more protection in
the pocket so that he could thrive now I
know Baker's success rates and his
passer rating is not so good even when
he's not pressured right or far this
year but there's some route concepts and
things of that nature that they need to
improve upon but when you look at the
numbers okay and I look at his passing
splits there appears to be this defense
mechanism from people in Cleveland that
they can't use more 12 personnel because
they're tight ends aren't healthy they
don't I heard that during the broadcast
Laska okay they were like oh they would
they he thinks he said Ricky Steele's
Jones is hurt right now because they'd
love to use multiple tight end sets but
he's hurt so they can't do it I think
schloredt said that on the broadcast
okay
so she'll Aerith the fact is that they
use 12 personnel some during the game so
let's share the results of when they use
12 versus they use the lab sure they've
used much more 11 but when they use 12
they had a 67 percent success rate
passing the football and Baker averaged
ten point four yards per attempt with a
110 passer rating Wow when they used 11
that 64 / 67 percent success rate
dropped down to 42 percent ten point
four yards per attempt was six yards per
attempt and a 1/10 passer rating was an
88 passer rating so with the injured
tight ends that they had without Rickey
seals Jones out on the field all the
injuries taken into consideration
because you're actually playing the game
with the people that are healthy yeah
they are crushing from 12 and much
weaker from 11 so you're telling me even
if you don't have let's say your number
one tight end
you should still do the personnel
because as you've always said you
need to confuse a defense you need to
show run to one protect your quarterback
to confuse the defense and to open up
passing lanes and the fact that they're
still relying on 11 shows maybe Freddie
kitchens really does not care about
stats because if he saw this he'd make a
change and maybe give his up-and-coming
quarterback that shaving his facial hair
three times in a day because he's going
I'm not playing up to snuff right maybe
it'll give him the confidence to maybe
make those better plays exactly he
something needs to change there Baker
what a lot of different things you hit
on a couple of them the other thing is
that when you're in 12 you're seeing a
different defense right the defense not
just maybe an ankle maybe you get base
exactly right and so you're gonna have
different personnel out there that you
might be able to take advantage of more
and even if this is my issue with Sean
McVeigh in the Superbowl right they
think that and granted Cooper cup was
injured so they definitely should have
used more 12 right but they think like
well my two tight ends aren't that great
and this is a really good pass rush so
they're not gonna be able to do much in
pass protection anyways so I'm not gonna
worry about using a lot of 12 I'm gonna
still stick with 11 because my
quarterbacks come with it the fact of
the matter is if you stick a tight end
out there okay
and I saw a key play in that game where
they almost had cooks in a big like 30
yard touchdown they were on the Patriots
29 I think through the ball after a
music we love using 12 they stuck both
tight ends in past protection it was
like the first or second time the entire
game that they actually use both tight
ends kept them in there in pass
protection and guess what the guys got
in I elated by the defensive end but you
know what it took the defensive end in
extra 1.5 to 2 seconds to get there and
Jared Goff had a wide open pocket in
front of him to step up into to deliver
the perfect ball down the field it was a
little bit too long and it took him a
little bit too long to throw the pass
yes
and then McCrory got back and broke it
this is gonna be hard for me to say
because this is the players podcast the
reason that I wanted to make this the
players podcast is because it is a
prevailing notion that is often correct
that almost every player in this league
is replaceable that if the Niners can't
play with Tevin Coleman they can do with
Raheem moster they can't do with Raheem
most hurt
with Matt Brina they can't do with Matt
Brito they can do it with Jeff Wilson
how often do you see a guy come off the
street and he's able to have success if
Ricki seals Jones is not in the game
Freddie kitchens do you know how much
that impacts the line in Vegas zero
nothing right there's one position on a
football team that impacts the line and
that's if your quarterback is not
playing
it's just proven everything else is not
that big of a deal and just because
they're not playing does it mean you
have to abandon that formation I think
it's a little bit of the pressure of
getting the ball with our wide receivers
too but Freddie kitchens I know that you
don't look at stats but you need to find
somebody to look at stats for you
because you're nuts you're not self
scouting you're looking at the film and
you're going these routes aren't right
we're not getting it done you need
someone to look at the statistics for
you because this is not nerd talk bro
this isn't comparing yards per carry and
and it's like arbitrary this is about
formation usage this is about trends
this is about learning what your
opponent's weakness is and not just
going what did Vrabel do in week six
let's do that in week 11 it's not
[ __ ] like that these aren't just
people that are like Mull if you divide
by no it's like people that understand
the game and it's just frustrating and
and I I thought that Freddie kitchens
was gonna keep this child til next year
because of how much easier the schedule
gets but when you lose to Brandon Allen
and the Denver Broncos I don't know how
much easier the schedule is going to get
I thought he was gonna keep the job
because they'll win three or four games
the end of the year they'll go oh they
got better as the year went on but if
you're not looking at stats and you're
not looking to improve and you're just
going we got to work harder get the [ __ ]
out just get out
because you're hurting everybody else's
career I didn't mean I didn't even know
I was gonna get that emotional I I like
the vigor I like the you know the and
you're right because it does affect
people's careers yes I think what a lot
of people don't realize is how much
coaching decision-making game-planning
play-calling
affects the livelihood of
in that building it's much more than
just oh well we didn't give ourselves
the very best shot at winning this game
like that compounds itself over and over
and over and then suddenly guys don't
look as good right quarterbacks aren't
playing as well yes and because they're
not in the best situations now I will
say this for Freddie kitchens because
I'm not in the building and I don't talk
to the right so I don't know they
brought in Todd Monken and I don't know
people are clamoring on Twitter let's
use more Todd Monken we could use more
Todd Monken well guess what Freddie
kitchens when he got put in charge last
season used a lot more 12 personnel they
use a lot less number of wide receivers
Todd Monken came from Tampa Bay where
they used three and four wide receivers
other than tight end very all right it
was spread formation he comes from an
air raid background now I know Baker has
some experience with that but that was
in college that was with a great a great
coach in college yeah that's not the
protocol my offensive line that would
dwarf people does exactly the next thing
I was going to say behind a bad
offensive line right and Baker is short
and Baker's playing behind a bad
offensive line against man crushers that
are trying to rip his head off on the
other side of him a few feet away from
where he's taking snaps from under
center or in shotgun and maybe the
answer guess what is not Todd Monken
maybe the influence of that offense even
though Todd's not calling plays he
helped install a new offense this
offseason yeah maybe his influence of
using the three-wide sets and the more
spread is the problem and getting more
Todd Monken is not the solution and
responsible we say all this Browns are
three-point favorites against the six
and two bills this week it's [ __ ]
wild like we say all this the sky is
collapsing and a six and two team is
coming to them and there are three point
favorites okay all right let's look at
your baby
Edie SR early down success rate last
week four and one straight up three one
in one against the spread Hey
Buccaneers thank you so much for that
push would have been a really
nice win San Francisco beat Arizona did
not cover against the spread I talked
about how earlier it's incredible health
Tevin Coleman catches that ball we maybe
don't see the Andy Isabella play but
anyway
Houston your EDS are was right you were
doubting it a little bit I was but
Houston goes out there and she lacks
Jacksonville and you're in shoe and wind
straight up went against the spread
Buffalo one straight up one against the
spread and you said the Raiders had a
big EDS are advantage against the Lion
they won straight up and against the
spread as well good week for EDS are
again and on the season 14 and three
overall nine seven and one against the
spread not bad no and I'll just caution
people that I don't we're using these
top four edges right each week because
it was a great idea on your part and you
wanted to call attention to these games
I do have a predictive EDS are model I
don't just take like what are the top
four mismatches and go bet them because
all the spreads are very different right
a lot of these are like double digit da
doubled is your favorite on panel and
I'm not like laying double-digit
favorites on these games so you would
expect a very strong 14 and 3 straight
up right but a much worse 80s record the
biggest thing is those underdogs when
we're finding underdogs that do have a
need es our edge that's pretty big right
those are highly bankable all right so
then let's kind of go quickly over the
huge EDS our matchups that are double
digits yeah you're number one ETS are
mismatch of week ten no surprise here
Indianapolis over Miami they're a ten
point favorite and I know coming up in
our schedule mismatches the Colts are
like number one and almost all of them
because when you play Miami you have a
mismatch right now the issue with the
Colts and the this dolphins to Kobe and
all that's Jacobi's most likely not
there so you're on a third string Brian
Hoyer you're also without tu I Hilton
and the dolphin that you're also without
Paris Campbell - yes you're right
no Paris Campbell and the Dolphins are
actually a little bit better metric wise
that's right yeah then they were with
Josh Rosen earlier in the season so you
know year-to-date EDS our numbers show a
big edge there
the hard part for the Dolphins is that
they are coming off of a big upset win
their first verse for the season or in
Gatorade early
spot for them but this has all the
makings of the EDS RS as India is that
much better but because there are
double-digit favorite and there's so
many weird things going on both sides
this is a I'll push that to the side and
yeah leave it for the squares yeah I
would I have zero interest I would never
lay the Colts at this number with those
injuries in the situations that they've
got going on there is a good coaching
mismatch there I did however pick up
chester Rogers and fantasy
he should have success I hope so alright
number two EDS are mismatched a little
bit of a closer spread Rams
with a monster EDS are advantage over
the Steelers this is a little scary
Steelers are three and a half point dogs
it is in Pittsburgh the Rams are coming
off of a bye Brandon cooks is not going
to play with the concussion and the
Steelers are winners of three straight
and are now surprise surprise
back into the wild-card discussion how
do you look at this with Rams having
this advantage over the Steelers it's
hard this is the road golf situation
right where Jared guy does not play
quite as well on the road as he does at
home this is a defensive line that they
didn't have the best day last week but
that was against a very good Colts
offensive line let's talk about yeah the
Steelers defensive line did not have a
good day against the Colts very good
offensive war this week they're going up
against the Rams offensive line which is
dramatically worse and that's the
perfect sound effect thing so they
struggled tremendously and that's going
to be a concern Goff under pressure on
the road is a recipe for disaster
right and you don't have Brandon cooks
as well but there is undoubtedly you
know the one good thing talking about
the Rams is Todd Gurley extra week to
rest a week to feel a little bit make
more face it was an extra week to
prepare right so hopefully I mean it
didn't work so well in the Super Bowl
but hopefully that is gonna help them in
this game here and you're right I
actually don't want to talk about
McVeigh with extra time to prepare
against humans because the last time we
pimped that out Kyle Shanahan whooped
that ass yeah because he's Kyle Shanahan
Kyle so is this a game though like I had
people downstairs that were like it was
the bye team on the road against the
Nanda
this year is like oh and five is this
something like I know people downstairs
are circling going I like the Steelers
here is that the is that the sharp side
of that matchup even though II DSR is
telling you the Rams have a huge
advantage it's hard this one I have not
seen anybody from any of the syndicate
groups that I look into on either side
of this one another definitely this line
was for at some spots it's now coming
down it's trending lower right so if you
like the Steelers now might be the time
to move if you like the Rams maybe
denial 3 yeah wait it out a little bit I
don't have a strong feeling on this game
though I will say I'm very surprised at
how well the Steelers have been doing
with Mason Rudolph the one thing that
Mason Rudolph struggles with is if you
get pressure on him
so can the Rams get pressure they really
haven't done a great job of that so far
this season but if you could get some
pressure Mason Rudolph does struggle
shout out to the Steelers defense
because that's really been the unit
that's been carrying it from Minka
Fitzpatrick it in pick sixes they lose
Stefon to it and they're still able to
get pressure and TJ watt and bud Dupree
I mean bud Dupree is one of those guys
that gets killed on the internet every
year for not having good agility and
Bend but they've been able to create
havoc for quarterbacks lately and it's
it's been what's kept this team afloat
shout out the Tomlin on that one play
where there was a fumble I loved I saw
the replay where bud Dupree instead of
and and this is what more teams need the
coach to be honest okay this is
something and more teams need to coach
instead of just immediately grabbing the
quarterback right when his ball was was
was right in his grasp he waited he was
hovering with his hand if you watch he
was hovering over the shoulder of the
quarterback waiting for the quarterback
to bring the ball off that gear for it
and then he hit it yeah and more teams
what if like my influence on teams like
I mostly help offensively but from a
defensive perspective and and and less
special team from that defensive
perspective it is so vitally important
if you can get a turnover to house that
puppy if you can get your guys to
practice downfield blocking and the
return to delays because the difference
in like expected points added EPA
when you can return a score for a
touchdown versus getting tackled even if
you're getting tackled at like the
25-yard line by the other team right
it's so much more efficient to actually
get that touchdown on the return so when
I any means necessary to touchdown or a
special teams touchdown I usually look
at the game and go it's over because
it's like 80 percent yeah that a team
that scores defensively or special teams
wins the game and then if they're
leading at halftime 80 percent times 80
percent I don't even know how that works
I think you win a hundred and sixty
percent of the times okay that's it's
not real Oh TVs ma you're going that's
not how well numbers work okay third eds
are mismatched the third biggest Ravens
over Bengals Ravens are 10-point
favorites this is a lot like Indy Miami
where I go man there's a lot of
storylines here that I don't [ __ ]
like like Ravens are coming off game of
the year
yeah game of the year against the
Patriots and what's funny is is how did
the Packers lose to the Chargers and
then you think the week before they went
into Kansas City and they beat was it in
Kansas ear land off Kansas City went
into Kansas City and want to shootout on
Sunday Night Football and then I wonder
why they were a little bit dead the next
week they're human this is what happens
so the Ravens are coming off of that and
then you also said that they have a lot
of big games coming up with a schedule
that when you're playing Cincinnati
you're like oh we can handle the Bengals
and also if AJ Green plays nobody tears
up the Ravens historically like AJ
greens but what's the upcoming schedule
for the Ravens that they might look past
right so they've got a big home game
next week against the Houston Texans
which is obviously huge for playoff
implication and then they also play in
the coming weeks the Rams and the 49ers
so like those are this is no stretch of
the Ravens right where we're gonna find
out is the big stretch they also have a
game against the Buffalo Bills and they
closed the season last two weeks the
Browns and the Steelers but the key is
as you mentioned you know when we're
handicapping games we're looking at
numbers we're looking at matchup right
but we also have to account
in some respect for the human aspect the
ability to get up for games it's very
difficult to get up for multiple games
in a row and when you crush a team like
the Patriots in the fashion that they
did at home and then you have to go on
the road against a team that you should
be able to crush right well we know that
they played the Bengals once before they
played the Bengals at home and it was
close the entire game this spread was 10
and what was the final score they only
won by 6 and and now they did get over I
think it was a return touchdown the
fantasy of the game that was a huge Mark
Ingram game they were running the ball a
ton and you're like oh they have this
game in the bag and then it was Bengals
touchdown at the end Bengals were gonna
go I think they may've even got an
onside kick in that game but I just know
that the Bengals were hanging around
they should not have been there that
entire game no and if you're taking 10
points if you're catching 10 points on
the road in Baltimore I know you got
Ryan Finley a quarterback right but how
much of a downgrade is he over Andy
Dalton a little bit but now you're at
home and you're still catching 10 points
I mean is he really worth it was right
what Andy Dalton was giving you really
that much of a step up over what whine
Finley's going to be given right I don't
know I liked what seemed right and the
Ravens defense is much improved but they
really don't have any pass rushers which
has been like one of their Achilles
heels all year but if AJ Green plays the
last time he faced them five catches 69
yards three touchdowns they if you Wow
how about this one two three four five
six the last seven times the Bengals
have faced the Ravens with AJ Green in
the lineup the Bengals are 6 and 1 whoa
in their last nine they're 7 and 2 now
he hasn't always gone off he had a 2 for
17 of 5 for 74 but in the other games 10
for 227 and 2 touchdowns 6 for 131 and 1
touchdown 8 for 151 and 1 touchdown
AJ Green loves ballin against the Ravens
we don't know his health we don't know
the motivation of the Ravens this is a
game where I feel like if you are
betting it the only side that makes
sense is taking the points and the
Bengals but there's a lot of
you're also betting on Ryan Finley in a
really shitty offensive line so it's
it's all over the place but if I if I
were to Beto be on the Bengals it's one
of those games where if you bet the
Bengals and they cover and and the
public's all over the Ravens after what
they just did you're you're seeing how
many times you could pat yourself on the
back all right you're like that you gif
where you're just like absent yourself
on the back over over if you lose then
you're just like you're like I bet on a
Ryan Finley against the six and two
Baltimore Ravens right yeah but I'd
always rather side against the public
and take a team that nobody thinks is
really going to cover then then you know
take the team that everybody thinks
should win this game outright and should
easily cover the spread
your fourth biggest mismatch it is
giving me hives I don't want to say it
out loud you have the Bucks as a huge
mismatch over the Cardinals and the
Bucks are four and a half point
favorites and there's a little revenge
factor in this game Warren yeah a little
bit
you know Bruce Arians game is in Tampa
by the way the games in Tampa I think
they left pretty amicably I mean I think
Bruce was citing health issues as
opposed to being fired and whatnot but
you wonder like they weren't doing that
well record wise and you wonder if there
was more pressure being put on him from
the bidwells and in any respect or
something like that behind the scenes I
can't speculate I don't know it's just
you wonder if that like was contributing
to why he said I'm not having fun
anymore doing this I love my players I
love the guys on my coaching staff but
I'm not having I'm not enjoying this
anymore
and it's hurting my health so I've got a
I've got to retire here but there
definitely is a big edge for the Bucks
in this game but it's another one of
those games where you know we saw Jameis
throw a bunch of pics
two weeks prior and we saw Bruce Arians
come out and say this wasn't his fault
at all right this was all on the
receivers now he has like fumbles and
mistakes and and whatnot and you know at
some point enough is enough like you
know you can't keep having the same
mistakes happen over and
and assume that it's always somebody
else's fault I have heard from some
sources that this will be James's last
year I think it makes sense does notes
here well in Tampa yeah yeah notes here
from Ingrid Cardinals are four and one
against the spread in their last five
road games we've seen the Cardinals
perform well in the road science games
specifically Cardinals averaging almost
their games are averaging around 50
points combined bucks games are
averaging around 60 points combined
over/under in this game is 52 if I was
gonna bet anything in this game the over
is what kind of sounds the most sensible
to me yeah I mean it definitely looks
like the way to go I can't comment on it
right now alright that means there could
be action coming forward and you know
you could figure out where Warren
eventually ends up sharp football
analysis calm this week all of the pics
are free we'll see if that ends up being
one we did not prepare that question and
you could tell that Warren's going left
oh shut the [ __ ] up
other mismatches this is the section
where last week you gave us Raiders over
Lyons edr EDS are mismatches that kind
of jumped out to you is maybe not the
top four but other ones and it's one
that you said
bills at Browns you see an EDS are
advantage for the bills in this game
again they are a three point dog in
Cleveland why are you still kind of I'm
not certain about this is because the
bills are like the perfect six and two
team to bet against every week right now
yes I think so it's tough right
everybody's writing off Freddie kitchens
everybody's writing off the Cleveland
Browns but the one thing that Cleveland
should be able to do here is run the
football and the best friend and we'll
talk about it momentarily of any team
that's playing a good defense is the
ability to be able to run the football
and if you can run on the Buffalo Bills
you alleviate a lot of your problems you
make play-action a lot more effective so
that is the concern number one and then
concern number two is is your going up
against Josh Allen they have not gotten
their downfield passing game to work so
will they really be able to
distance you know this game's gonna be
tight it's going to be close throughout
it's just like the game in Denver and
the Browns had I think six or seven
drives inside the Denver Broncos
twenty-five or thirty yard line and they
only walked away with what 19 points I
mean that type of thing should not
happen it likely won't happen again
I want Freddie kitchens to go back to
what I saw him doing last year down in
the red zone where he was like read
optioning a running back faking a pitch
and then handing it off to Jarvis Landry
who was streaking across on the jet
sweep running into the end zone and then
Baker Mayfield doing his little arm
thing because he fooled everybody and
the defense had no clue and this guy's
already in the end zone doing a tap
dance and the Browns are celebrating
that's what we need to get out of the
Browns I love Sean McDermott it's a
tough opponent the bills are a good
opponent but they there's just something
here I think with the wind and the
weather there could be the situation
where whichever team runs the ball
better and stops the run and both teams
are good at running and both defenses
are bad at stopping the run it's
whichever one is able to execute that
better bills are six and one against the
spread in their last seven as underdogs
four and three straight up bills are
five and one against the spread in their
last six Road games I guess my question
here is it's one thing to go okay the
Browns maybe Vegas is go and secretly we
think that they might have the advantage
here but to open the line as a two and a
half point favorite over the bills is
kind of what shocked me where you would
I just didn't understand opening the
line at that can you explain to me how
Vegas why Vegas would do something like
that that the thinking behind that well
it's obviously three-point line is a
home-field advantage so they're assuming
now that the Buffalo Bills are a little
bit better and they're trying to
essentially I think get the action to
balance itself out but inevitably what's
probably gonna happen here is you're
gonna be a little bit lopsided on the
Buffalo Bills has to be so you're gonna
hope as the book sometimes books will do
this they'll be willing to take a little
bit of position
you know they'll they'll publicly state
and some of these guys now do podcast
and whatnot like it'd be really big for
the house which what they mean right if
the Browns can win this game by three or
more points right we want the Browns to
win this game we would lose money if the
Browns but the fact of the matter is
lets us think in all seriousness yeah
this is a one o'clock kickoff between
the freakin Browns and the bills how
many people are actually even betting on
this game right I think a lot you do I
just I don't think there's gonna be a
lot of volume on this game I'll be very
this is one I'd like to check in
afterwards I just think that you know
when you're when you're betting football
and then that one line pops up and it
scares you because you're like what how
is this possible but then that's why you
wouldn't want to bet on it yeah but I
think that's where the squares bet
I think the squares are gonna pour their
money in on the bills I write I don't
know I do you see the record right it's
a six and two versus a two and six but
and you're getting two and a half you're
getting three right and so the guys that
are going to bet this game are betting
the bills but how many guys are looking
at this and saying I've just been dying
to take the Josh Allen and the bills on
the road here like I feel like most of
the guys are gonna be like I want Drew
Brees at home right the Saints at home I
want Aaron Rodgers at home right I
whatever I want if Patrick mahomes come
back I want to take him against like the
end I think that watching sports media
all week and watching people [ __ ] on the
Browns like we just did a whole thing
about Freddie kitchens not doing
analytics there was Baker Mayfield
shaving his face
there was Odell Beckham yelling to
himself on the sidelines this is
America's favorite circus and the bills
are this team where they just won you
know and a double did you game against
Washington and people are going then the
bills might make the playoffs I can get
three points and Bennigan's Baker I just
I don't know it just I think you're
definitely right the public is no doubt
about it gonna come in on the Buffalo
Bills here I just know I'm the sick [ __ ]
that's like that means I need to call in
the Browns yeah well yeah this is the
smart way to make money yeah but the
problem is is like I'm done betting on
the Browns in the Bucs
I really am yeah you might need to be I
mean this this
a tough game right the Bills have the
ESR advantage they are the better team I
love their coaching staff but like they
could be destroying a team and be up 9
nothing and like all it takes is one
Odell slant to go 80 yards and I look
like an idiot you know
yeah well the fact of the matter is if
you want to go back and look go back and
look at the last three games that the
Cleveland Browns have played they have a
great shot at beating the Denver Broncos
team Denver probably maybe should have
if that games played out like 10 times
they'd probably win that game 6 times
right but because it's just a one-off
game they ended up losing it they had a
they should have covered that game up in
New England if they fumble the ball and
hang on to it if they don't turn the
ball over in their end like that's so
stupid with the pitches and whatnot if
they don't do that type of thing they
might have a they know if I have a shot
of losing that game by just one score
keeping that thing super close and then
the prior game they lost to the Seattle
Seahawks that was a 20 to 32 game that's
a 4.0 like 73 right and remember a few
weeks earlier they beat the Baltimore
Ravens so this is not a team in a
Cleveland Browns they have a terrible
record but this is not a team that is
overall a terrible team they've got
talent and I think they've got like
minimum level coaching they need to
clean up something here I don't think
they're coaching stairs my biggest
factor with what you just said it
applies to the Bucs and the Browns
if they just don't do those mistakes
they'd be fine I have not seen that
they're capable of not making those
mistakes some teams just [ __ ] up a lot
yeah they don't have good coaching they
don't have good fundamentals they don't
have structure and so every week we go I
mean if they don't just fumble and
Jameis doesn't just have a weird
interception and bigger doesn't make a
bad decision it's every [ __ ] week
right and so it's like I've lost five
blackjack hands in a row can't lose six
like I it's it's tough yeah so but of
course the smart side is always to go
this can't continue but when it when
you're all I just don't want to keep
laying down on the railroad tracks look
here's the thing about betting in
general you want to put yourself in plus
evie situations right you will not
always win those bets okay you have
to accept the fact you're right these
teams when you're up at halftime you
when 80% of the time there's still 20%
of the time this they don't win this is
a one-off game this is a one-off game
and you I'm not advocating that you bet
the Cleveland Browns here I'm just
talking in general that betting again if
the public is 80 to 90% on the Buffalo
Bills in this game I'm just telling you
they may win the bills may win outright
by 14 points right books can get
slaughter and the books get slaughtered
but the fact of the matter is over time
if you're collecting 20 or 30 bets over
a three four year period where you're
taking the team that's 10% that the
public is you know the 90% of the public
is on the other side you are going to be
winning 54 55 58 percent of those wagers
which is all you need to do to make
money so you're not gonna win a hundred
percent of them and you may lose this
one but siding with the public in these
games is generally a scary proposition
unless all of your handicapping and all
of your thoroughness shows you that this
is by far the right side and you feel
confident you could still lose even if a
game's the right side we know this this
is betting the balls shaped funny it
bounces weird ways turnovers win 80% of
the time you can have a muffed punt and
that's the game that's just that simple
and it's a complete accident didn't have
anything to do with offense or defense
it was a freaking special teams muffed
punt and you lose your wager that's
gambling I know it's awful
alright strength of schedule but fun
yeah it's the best sighting oh it's all
I figure 80 I can't even watch the games
if I know about all right let's go to
strength of schedule
how what teams have faced for the last
few weeks what they faced this season
compared to what they faced this week I
was not lying
literally when it comes to pass and run
the number one team in terms of having
faced really tough and it gets easier
this week is the Colts we are not going
to go into that there are too many
variables and it's the Dolphins throw
out the window
it doesn't matter last week I believe it
was dictated the easiest pass shift was
the Cowboys and what do you know dak
Prescott goes out there nice
jeno michael Gallup could touch on the
end tamari Cooper he had that early
interception I think messed him up but I
think over time he was able to kind of
enjoy that Eevee Plus matchup plus Eevee
my bet
so which which team beyond the Colts
this week has the easiest pass offense
shift in strength of schedule for week
10 it's the New Orleans Saints not
really surprising they're playing the
Atlanta Falcons the 32nd ranked to pass
the offense they say both are coming off
a bye right yes both coming off a bye
the Saints have a great passing offense
that was led by Teddy Bridgewater now
Drew Brees is back everybody thought
wise Drew Brees coming out against
Arizona Colonels by the way that game
was much closer than the 31 to 9 final
so we're initiated Drew Brees did throw
one bad interception but he is going to
be probably playing a lot better in this
game after having two weeks to cover
further from the hand injury that he may
be rushed back a little bit too quickly
from against the Arizona Cardinals now
you're planted does get back Marcus
Trufant in the secondary hmm but it
still is you know you look at the past
defenses he's played three straight the
the Saints have played three straight
past defenses that ranked in the top 15
including two of them on the road well I
went to Jacksonville they went to
Chicago and now they get to take on the
Atlanta Falcons at home in the dome with
Drew Brees Saints are 17 and 2 straight
up at home in their last 19 games 12 and
7 against the spread Falcons on the road
in their last 20 games 4 and 16 against
the spread the spread in that game is 13
that's a little bit too big there was
one other passing offense that you
thought had had a pretty big advantage
too and that was my favorite team in the
world the Tampa Bay Buccaneers taking on
the Cardinals this could be a huge
Jameis spot huh maybe they'll finally
throw the ball to OJ Howard and save my
fifth round draft pick in fantasy that'd
be nice
yeah the Arizona Cardinals if you look
at what Jameis is played they played he
played the Rams and the Saints and the
Panthers all of which are top 15 then
they had a bye
they came back and played the Titans in
the Seahawks now we know the Titans in
the Seahawks aren't upper-echelon
right but they're their average past
defenses slightly below average the
Arizona Cardinals are pretty bad now
Patrick Peterson is there now so that
past defense is improving right ahead to
what their full season long numbers are
but you could still move the ball
through the air I mean Jimmy Garoppolo
absolutely torched them and and used
Emmanuel Sanders for the first time and
Emmanuel Sanders was insane Jimmy
Garoppolo succeeded so much against the
Cardinals that people had to apologize
to Jimmy G for like riding him all year
and and the number one sentence after
that Thursday night game was if Jimmy G
can play like this all year they're
going to the Super Bowl and people don't
realize it's the Arizona Cardinals pass
defense please understand this is a
matchup League yes what happens
run splits who has Marlin Mac and the
Colts have the easiest run split taking
on the Dolphins we throw that out number
two Christian McCaffrey and the Carolina
Panthers here we go now it begins
because you said for Christian McCaffrey
even though it got easier the rest of
the year
Sunday last week was still tough with
the Tennessee Titans and he still did
that yeah and now he gets to take on a
beautiful matchup a beautiful we're
gonna talk about this one
later when we break down the games but
Christian McCaffrey the easiest run
defense that he will face all season at
this point in the Packers is the Green
Bay Packers LT ranked 26th against the
run and Carolina has played the number
one toughest schedule of opposing run
defenses year-to-date in their eight
games they have played five run defenses
that ranked in the top five Wow
so that's insane and Christian McCaffrey
still put up the numbers that he has now
he gets to face the easiest of the
season for him and there's a lot of
things that match up pretty well for the
rushing attack for Carolina here
definitely some of the circle and man
I mean Christian McCaffrey as having I
don't want to into the MVP discussion
but I think it's it's really fun this is
an all time fantasy season like we I
don't know if I've ever seen
this is like the Sean Alexander year
this is like a two thousand yard year I
really hope he has two thousand yards
Christian McCaffrey hitting two thousand
yards would be like when Russell
Westbrook averaged a triple-double for
the season and people felt old and MBA
people felt the need to make russell
westbr westbrook the MVP because we
never seen that before
McCaffrey is gonna make this MVP
discussion very difficult if he gets to
like $3,000 pacy ARDS or does something
we really haven't seen before I think I
hear you a hundred percent I think it's
going to be tough because for the very
same reason that you mentioned earlier
in the show about how coaches are
getting criticized now for not being as
aggressive the not just like the total
hardcore analytics community but more of
Twitter is becoming more intelligent
because people are sharing information
that's being digested that shows how
much more valuable passing is than
running so it's going to be hard in this
era oh if you hear where Russell Lamar
and DeSean or dumped all you're doing
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be very
hard but you know that's that's not a
bad thing Christian McCaffrey is in a
league of his own right now make them
the offense we live here we need to give
him the props that he's due I just want
him to stay healthy with this heavy
workload and destroy the rest of your
run defense schedule as much as you
possibly can and then let's let the
chips fall where they may but I wish him
good health and good luck
easiest defensive shift we saw last week
it was the Browns and they really did
play well if you take away the no
offense 75 yard touchdown with the
Browns it was tackling issues I don't
know if the scheme was the issue it's
just every big Broncos play it was
Philip Lindsay or Noah fan getting out
of three guy's arms the the biggest
defensive shift+ evie this week what do
you know the New York Giants but their
defense kind of stinks so yeah it's it's
hard I mean they they go from playing
the Cowboys who's like one of the best
offenses in the NFL right now the Lions
the Cardinals and the Patriots in the
last four weeks to playing the NFL's
worst offense now
the Jets metric wise are the worst
offense there's a couple weeks of Luke
McCown in there folk but the fact of the
matter is the Jets do have more talent
overall than being the worst offense in
the NFL and at some point it's got a
clique for them like at some point
they're going to get back on track
what better defense to get on track than
the New York Giants all of that being
said they do face right a nice season
schedule here from playing all those
difficult offenses now the Lions are a
two and a half point underdog but
they're actually number two in the
easiest defensive shift taking on the
Bears yes they are and we know Mitchell
true Biscay is just like Sam d'arnot
right now people like what the hell's
going on with this guy a little bit
different because people like Sam last
year and are what's gates doing with Sam
this year true Biscay was always being
kind of like coddled and brought along
and people always were a little bit more
skeptical of him but definitely when you
talk about the Detroit Lions they were
playing apart from the game against the
Giants they were playing a lot of good
offenses you're talking about the
Raiders the Packers the Vikings the
cheese over the last four or five games
now they get to play the Chicago Bears
who obviously are struggling right now
through the air now Chicago could turn
to the run go a little bit more run
heavy have some success against the
Lions poor run defense but that's the
definite edge there is that the Lions
get to face a much easier offense than
they've been accustomed and sure Biscay
has only damn it I put the wrong team in
there I want to see how true Biscay has
done against the Lions how do you think
he's done so far what's your guess in
his career average he has Mitchell true
Biscay and I blew it man sometimes Pro
Football Reference is hard sometimes
it's not today it's decided to be a
little bit more difficult try Biscay
against the Lions get results sort him
out Adam left go stalling he is how
about this 23 of 34 355 and three
touchdowns last year he went 179 one
touchdown no interceptions the year
before and 314 watched at one touchdown
three interceptions but the last time
they played
he dropped 355 three touchdowns with a
149 QB rating but that was also I don't
even want to look at last year as Bears
team compared to this year they're not
the Saints depressing it's depressing if
you were to do that so yeah the only
other team that you have rated as the
easiest defensive shift was the Ravens
facing the Bengals and now they're
facing Ryan Finley so something to keep
an eye on let's talk about the games the
week first one we're gonna do four
o'clock Packers Panthers the one we were
talking about before what else do you
want to get into this game that that has
caught your eye whether it's the
possible snowfall whether it's the fact
that we definitely know that Cam
Newton's out right now and this is Kyle
Allen's team or the fact that the
Packers are coming off of a very
disappointing loss in the Los Angeles
chargers yeah there was some interesting
things come out after that game actually
I think it was like during the game
where the sideline reporter interviewed
Matt Lafleur and he was saying that he
was disappointed because they got to the
stadium late they changed up some things
with their practice schedule though and
he felt like that was to blame by the
team sleepy start and their overall
performance in that game which is a
little odd and you would think that
those types of things would rectify
themselves at home right being back on a
normal schedule so that's first and
foremost the second thing is like we've
been berating Melvin Gordon and this
Chargers rushing offense
ever since Melvin Gordon came back they
were trying to force-feed him the
football and it was terrible you know
what they did last week when they played
the Green Bay Packers were on defense
the prior three weeks
the Chargers rushing offense had a 17
percent success rate 21 percent success
rate and 24 percent success rate on the
ground against the Green Bay Packers
last week sixty-six percent success rate
Eckler and Gordon combined to run for a
hundred and fifty yards on the ground a
4.7 yards per carry so it goes to show
you how bad this Packers run defense is
playing right now they have allowed a
lot of yardage to some of the decent
rushing attacks like above-average
rushing attacks let me just throw out
some news Dowd McCook seven
point seven yards per carry against
these guys when they played the Eagles
mile Sanders had 6.5 and Jordan Howard
at 5.8 yards per carry
Josh Jacobs of the Niners of the Raiders
5.9 yards per carry and Zeek 5.2 it's
like these are the only above-average
rushing offenses that they faced and
every single one of these guys is having
between five and almost eight yards per
carry weird which is insane and now
you're going up against Christian
McCaffrey now what is what do the
Packers struggle with they struggle with
for you guys watching at home you're
gonna watch your TV and you're gonna
look at when the Green Bay Packers are
playing defense and the Carolina
Panthers are running towards the middle
or towards their left
that's where Green Bay is very
susceptible the offenses up the gut or
to the left of the offense that's where
we should expect Christian McCaffrey
have big runs that's where he's good
that's where the Green Bay Packers are
bad so there's a mirror image it favors
Carolina's running to their offensive
left every time they run up to the left
I want people to be tweeting at me and
Warren and being like to the left
Christian McCaffrey to the left alright
that's all I'm gonna pay attention to
now and in addition if you look at like
some of the rushing types they
definitely struggle against some of the
things that the Carolina Panthers do
well the Carolina Panthers run a lot of
power Green Bay's terrible against power
Carolina runs inside zone a lot now
they're very balanced they run inside an
outside zone but they like inside zone
and Green Bay is very bad defending
inside zone so the viewers at home you
guys 33% you reckon I really know inside
zone power all these different types of
run plays but just in general look
inside up the middle to the left that's
where they should have success on the
flip side though this matchup is really
interesting because I'm looking up
Christian McCaffrey prophets I just want
to say the Green Bay Packers actually
have a very good advantage on the ground
themselves both of these teams have good
advantages running the football right
because we saw the liner's run all over
Carolina ranks dead last in the NFL and
run defense
I must wild because their past defense
has been so phenomenal they're very much
of a run funnel right they are yeah so
you want to
you running the football on them the
other cool thing about this game that I
love when we get to this time of year we
start to see this one love snow football
game I love snow football games I don't
know that we're going to see snow we'll
have to see but the current forecast
right now shows very cold conditions to
call this football game of the year to
date I think the gametime kickoff
temperature is gonna be right around 27
28 degrees so below freezing I can't
wait to watch these guys play in the
cold with that you could see the breath
because the game kicks off for 25
daylight savings it's gonna be dark
earlier now there so we're gonna have
the night football under the lights at
Lambeau maybe a little bit of snow pile
up on the sidelines we'll have to see
and you got these cold breaths of air
coming out of there this is when we get
the war and sharp fan tweets where he's
just like I love football like this yes
well there's nothing better when I'm
sitting in my theater room with the
fireplace going in the foreground and
I'm on my chair and it only works when
there's only a couple games that on and
drivers if there's like four or five and
I'm studying them all but like in the
playoffs when the Chiefs played the
Colts last year where sweet Nelson was
out there and a tank top yeah and and
that was a game where I'm like the fires
going I'm watching it on the big screen
only one game spell in the whole screen
and it's just beautiful you can have a
drink in your hand with the fire going
and you're warm and they're freezing
their ass off but it makes for beautiful
TV there is nothing better than being
comfortable as other people are in
suffer this suffering through the cold
other four o'clock game that we wanted
to talk about was Vikings cowboys Kirk
Cousins in prime time Mike Zimmer
against the team that he used to coach
for where would you like to start
talking with two teams that are firmly
in the playoff picture
Vikings coming off of a very
disappointing loss where if I was a
Vikings fan and you got to play the
Chiefs without Patrick mahomes I need a
win I need to win that game especially
when you have a lead Cowboys start off
slow black cat runs on the field they
end up pulling out the win and and
handling the Giants but now it's the
Cowboys against a good team and the
Cowboys haven't been that great this
year against good teams how does this
matchup play in your mind
well I'm looking up statistics for Kirk
Cousins I'm looking up his win-loss
percentage when he does not play at one
o'clock oh there's a thing there there
there's a thing there where Kirk Cousins
does not play at one o'clock so let me
pull this up for you when Kirk Cousins
okay and and bear in mind that there
might be a game or two off here okay
there like it just might be a game or
two off because I'm looking it up from a
resource that I trust but it might not
be a hundred percent perfect okay Kirk
Cousins eight and twenty two straight up
when he plays at 425 or later whether
it's like a primetime game whether it's
a Sunday afternoon game he is horrid
twenty-two foreign sorry eight and
twenty okay heydon't well this includes
games with the Redskins since he's been
in Minnesota
hold on add another parameter here yeah
add those parameters three and seven
straight up in Minnesota when he's
played one of the afternoon kickoffs or
in prime time how do how do you explain
that like what comes to your mind well I
have heard that Kirk Cousins is very
very much a creature of habit like oh
that has such a massive routine for
these one o'clock games and when he does
not stick to that routine for these
later games it clearly
maybe he struggles I can't really
understand why I know when I was younger
and playing sports in high school and
you know in in in other leagues and
travel soccer and doing all these other
sports I loved playing under the lights
at night like that was it's funny
because those statistics are what we say
that people shrink in prime time and we
say that they're afraid of the big
moment but the way that you're kind of
proposing it is no Kirk is a creature of
habit and this is a weird schedule yeah
so it's not that he's afraid it's not
that he's like more people are watching
me right now because I have 8 min and
Buck on the call right that's so like we
thought of Andy Dalton right like Dalton
in prime time it's like all the eyeballs
are on and why is he keep blowing these
games with Kirk I mean he struggles even
in these four o'clock games where you
know it's not even
necessarily the national TV game so
that's one factor here but I look at
this gaming that's not the fact I hear
that and I know the degenerates out
there like oh I'm cashing that Cowboys
ticket all right what else do you have
those yeah but the main thing here is
both these teams really if you look at
their schedules really haven't played
anybody know if you look at the
Minnesota Vikings their offense has
played the second easiest schedule in
the NFL the Dallas Cowboys offense has
played the sixth easiest schedule in the
NFL the Dallas Cowboys defense has
played the fourth easiest schedule in
the NFL so these guys really haven't
played very many good opponents so this
games really gonna be a good measuring
stick now Dallas of course they have
played the Eagles they have played the
Packers and they have played the Saints
those are good measuring sticks as well
they went 2 and 1 in those games but
they've also played 1 and 2 in those
games
I'm sorry wanted to they've also played
the Giants twice the Redskins and the
Dolphins right like not very good teams
at all and you know if you look at the
Minnesota Vikings as well they stomp the
Falcons they they beat the Raiders not
that win looks a lot better now
but it does it does they lost to the
Green Bay Packers and the game against
the Chiefs other than that they're
playing you know the Falcons and the
Redskins there's bears etc so I think
this is going to be a good measuring
stick I'm really interested to see how
the Cowboys playing to attack these guys
are they gonna go with a little bit more
pass heavy attack you know they're all
their receivers are healthy they've got
a healthy offensive line right now could
they try to exploit some of those corner
backs who might be struggling in
coverage for the Minnesota Vikings
alternatively we don't have Adam Thielen
so Adam Thielen was like one of those
big-time security blankets for Kirk
Cousins and without Adam Thielen there
it's gonna be tough like funneling
everything through Dalvin cook and you
know expecting your other receivers to
step up for ya I have like the olih BC
Johnson has been a pleasant surprise
I think herb Smith I'm just seeing him
worked into the offense a lot more and
anytime I can get Rudolph and nervous
Smith in the field together and run a
little bit of 12 personnel I'm excited
about it how do you think Dallas has run
defense will hold up against Alvin well
Dallas has played v easy schedule of
opposing rushing offenses so far this
year
and it's definitely what the Minnesota
Vikings need the boring they need their
offensive line to establish some
physicality and be able to be productive
on the ground so that you don't put
everything on Kirk Cousins shoulders you
know you can't have everything on his
shoulders in this game because he
doesn't have feeling and he's in a
environment that he hasn't really
excelled in terms of the start time in
the location so definitely he is
familiar though from his time in
Washington or playing in this Shore so
he's got experience from that he's
definitely not going to be nervous about
playing in this venue but I think it's
gonna be fasting a malign perspective
from imbedding perspective I don't
really see any necessary value I think
the three-point line is pretty much
straight over it at home yeah I don't
really see that line moving too far off
the three I would probably lean towards
the Minnesota Vikings if I had to do
anything here one other note about
Cousins he is 6 and 28 against teams
with winning records in his career well
and we also know the statistic from my
book talking about Minnesota playing on
the road outdoors this games obviously
indoors in the dome but Mike Zimmer has
not really fared well I think they're
what like oh and 14 and 1 on the road
outdoors against teams with winning
records here they're playing indoors so
they're not they're not as far out from
their element you know but in my one
group chat we joke that Kirk Cousins is
the test of whether or not you're a good
team and so if you lose to Kirk Cousins
you're gonna finish the year under 500
if you beat them you have a chance to go
over 500 the litmus test so in my Eagles
chat when we lost to the Vikings it was
like guys were finished in 7 and 9 this
year Kirk Cousins beat us weren't under
500 team you'd be the vite I didn't the
Vikings beat you guys last year too and
Nui down to go to the playoffs and won
yeah I can't remember last year yeah I'm
pretty sure they may have lose all right
Monday Night Football
Seahawks Niners big game of the week
again Seahawks are coming in here they
could be down or Russell Wilson saving
them Niners beaten their chest got 10
days to prepare
Kyle Shanahan versus the sea
Hawks where do you want to start health
of the 49ers offense okay definitely
can't go are they all coming back
Staley's coming back McGlinchey is
coming back and Kylie's check is coming
back it's assuming they don't have any
type of they all practiced on Wednesday
they Tuesday or Wednesday and they all
reported that the practice went fine
right so as long as they have no like
unexpected setbacks later in the week
all those guys are coming back now it
should be noted that the San Francisco
49ers have played a tough schedule of
past rushes and they still are allowing
I think like the eighth lowest sack rate
in the NFL Wow so we met with the backup
with the backups which is saying
something for them right it's saying
something really strong for them and the
other thing about the Seattle Seahawks
is they do not rush the passer very well
at all Seattle struggles tremendously to
rush the passer in fact I'll pull it up
here but I'm pretty sure they are one of
the worst teams in the NFL at pass rush
efficiency they're number 31 and the
league at pass rush efficiency so I
think Jimmy G's gonna have time to throw
the football here I think you get the
tackles back you get your fullback back
who can help pick up some of those
Blitzers and Jimmy G's gonna have time
to survey this defense how healthy is
George Kittel will he be able to go to
be determined we still don't know that
yet but even without him we saw that
chemistry immediately with Manuel
Sanders and we meet about it on the
podcast Rich Eisen gorilla scangarelo he
came from that system this was
predictable we heard le that the thing
that excited me the most wasn't just the
way he was used there were so many times
in crunch time where Arizona clawed back
and the Niners were able to kind of have
that 5-6 minute drive to ice the game
and before every clutch throw when they
would break the huddle the two people
that would be talking to each other as
they would run to the line was Jimmy
Jean Emmanuel Sanders and they were
having a full-on conversation and for me
when you have a veteran wide receiver
because it's a very
young group of wide receivers on the
Niners and you have a quarterback that's
still getting used to the system and
still getting used to the personnel I
think the fact that they were
communicating that much that was in my
mind the missing piece for this Niners
offense they have the mismatch a tight
end
they have the mismatch at running backs
they have guys like debo Samuel that are
great for the jet sweeps to confuse a
defense but he did not have his reliable
wide receiver and he filled that gap
immediately and someone posted the video
on Twitter of a manual dusting Patrick
Peterson yeah multiple times throughout
that game he is that level of wide
receiver and I hope that everyone has
gotten past the he's a 30-plus year old
wide receiver coming off an Achilles and
realized he did it like he did it
Emmanuel Sanders did it
now let's live in this new normal and
stop being surprised by it and realizing
he could be the guy now I I love
Emmanuel Sanders he was a stud back when
Payton was with the Broncos sure we
forgot about him a little bit because
you had a couple different mouths to
feed and they'd had you flak when they
went with him or run heavy and they had
a couple year Trevor Simeon you know
super tall Brock Osweiler and they
didn't really have good quarterbacks
there he is going to be getting his
potential here with Kyle Shanahan and
Jimmy Garoppolo I can't wait to see that
so we know that Seattle struggles to put
pressure on a ship I forget how great he
was with the Pittsburgh Steelers yeah we
keep going he there is a there is a
definite edge for the 49ers offense here
both in the air and on the ground okay
and I think they're gonna have success
offensively and then flip to the other
side of the football here and this is
the most important thing about this game
that I find super fascinating the San
Francisco 49ers are great against the
pass but they're merely average against
the run really we saw the Arizona
Cardinals have a little bit of success
rub on them you're right can you drink
at a big game Christopher you still put
up some some yards on them with a
big-time touchdown run yeah they are
allowing actually what is it over the
last month their fifth worst and success
rate allowed on the ground and they are
allowing 5.4 yards
Carrie I have not heard this talked
about the Niners defense at all
33% listen up the Niners can be run on
and Seattle likes to run the football a
little bit so they should have some
success running the football here now
part of it is because of the style that
their defense coordinator plays with the
wide nine and he gets pressure from the
edges so easily but that opens up
running lanes right now the other
element here that's interesting is what
is San Francisco so damn good at they
are so damn good at getting pressure on
you and sacking you and disrupting your
passing attack yeah that rush through
what they're able to do up front however
you are now going up against the best
quarterback in the NFL when he's
pressured Russell Wilson is having a
phenomenal year when you look at the
games that he's played the three
toughest pass rush teams on the season
okay
his the three toughest a 26 28 to 26 win
over the Steelers where he threw for 300
yards 8.6 yards per attempt three
touchdowns no interceptions a 56%
success rate and a 131 rating a loss to
the Saints 33 to 27 the Saints had a
couple non offensive touchdowns in that
game he threw for four hundred and six
yards 8.1 yards per attempt two
touchdowns no interceptions a 50%
success rate and a 103 rating and then a
32 to 28 win over the Browns where he
threw for 295 yards at 8.9 yards per
attempt to touch on zone interception 61
percent success rate on the 118 rating
on the road he leads the NFL on
virtually every single metric when he's
under pressure he gets pressured 41% of
the time but he's only sacked 15% of the
time so he's avoiding those pressures
he's finding guys so when you talk about
who the 49ers have played so far listen
to these names and think in your mind
are these dudes who are good under
pressure that can evade that or these
guys that are going to get sacked and
deer-in-headlights
listen to this list all right I'll say
it out loud Baker Mayfield oh we know
he's a historically bad quarterback
under pressure Jared Goff same Mason
Rudolph
you may not know we get this car here
okay he was one of the worst in the NFL
Andy Dalton yes Jameis Winston Oh Krait
Case Keenum and Kyler Murray okay that's
that's who they hire is the only one but
Kyler goes down like so quick like he
you know he did okay he scrambling
around a little bit but he takes he eats
a little bit too many sacks in my
opinion I wish you would throw the ball
away a little bit more often as opposed
to take the sex but regardless he's a
rookie you're not as experienced so Russ
is going to present this element to this
particular defense that they haven't
seen before yet this year they're gonna
be able to maybe have a little bit of
success running the football hmm and
like if the 33% go to the website and
check it out I've already got something
up there on this game you do I'll just
tell them right now to save them the
trouble but you should read the write-up
it's one of many that I've got up there
by the time Sunday kicks off there'll be
several I like the over now again it's
all about timing the market and I got in
at a much better number than it is right
now I got in at what number 45 it was
actually we had to lay what - 120 to get
45 but we got 45 the line right now is
47 I still my model still thinks that
this total is about a point and a half
to short so I still think that there's
value in the 47 but then the real trick
comes into like the whole like what I do
most of my day is like having one eye on
the lines is somebody get a bet this
under since it opened a 45 44 and a half
and now is sitting up a 47 because if
then you could get over 46 later in the
week when should you go on this game
right so you got to worry about that now
if you did get in already
but you are already looking at it and
like you said the Seahawks can be run on
and the Niners we know have an
unbelievable running attack and the
Niners have not faced a quarterback that
can elude this phenomenal pass rush and
put up points add it to the fact that
Russell Wilson in 11 prime time games on
the road as last 11 eight two and one
straight up seven three and one against
the spread this is the this is only the
sixth time Russell Wilson is a six plus
point underdog in his career right now
the Niners are six and a half point
favorites do you know what his record
was and the other five games against the
spread when he was a six plus point dog
five you know five and Oh Seahawks are
also ten and one straight up in their
last 11 games when playing the Niners
it's a very different era for the Niners
this team is much very unlike those
teams but this is the year of Russel
Wilson it's been that way from the
offseason him and Ciara took it over
he took DK Metcalfe under his wing he
got the new contract Seattle we got a
deal this has this entire year has been
the year of Russell Wilson and another
interesting matchup yeah it's definitely
been the year of Wilson either so it's a
yeah but I like it I'm cool with it
Russell Wilson it is the year of Russell
Wilson and in addition they're getting
to face the Niners without a guy who's
very underrated in my opinion Quan
Alexander oh yeah I'm back speed
linebacker he'd be dealing with Chris
Carson the whole game and Russell Wilson
exactly and you take a guy like that
away from this defense there is going to
be a drop-off he's wanted I think you
we've ranked number 2 in past coverage
really good at past coverages this year
better than any of his years when he was
in Tampa Bay and what are the things
that we know about this pass rush right
this is this is one of the things I was
preaching on Twitter when I first saw
him go down and people like I don't even
know quanta Alexander was on the 49ers
this year because all we hear about is
beau so right but the factor here is
that you hear about Bosa and you hear
about that defensive line primarily on
the 49ers because they're the ones
getting sacks and getting pressure some
of them are coverage sex but if they
don't get those sacks guess who becomes
more important Quan Alexander and his
coverage ability down the field friend
more analysis and if Quan Alexander's
not there in a frost Wilson's escaping
some of that pressure
Kwan's absence in this game may be more
meaningful than Quan Alexander's absence
in other games where that front four can
get pressure and sacked the quarterback
I mean this is going to be we know the
Seattle Seahawks don't have a good
offensive line at pass protecting so
make no mistake like Rodgers games start
out really ugly for Russell Russell was
going to be under pressure here but it's
the fact that he's able to
you rise above that often times and
Excel is what makes this difficult in a
way that none of the other quarterbacks
the 49ers have faced and we're getting
the debut of Josh Gordon yeah I really
will I'm just gonna be yeah right what
roles or those types of things this
reminds me so much of Ravens Patriots
where we're sitting here and I'm hearing
you talk and I'm going wow the the six
and a half point dogs Seahawks much like
the Ravens last week sound like the
smart way to go if I was going to pick a
side but then there's the other part
where I'm going
it's Kyle Shanahan with ten days and
it's not a great run defense against a
running monster that now has two
offensive tackles and a fullback at
their disposal it's this is a great game
it really is gonna be great I want to
see the coaching matchup hear what the
Seahawks decide to do will they try to
pass will they stick with Iran will they
fall behind enough to turn more to rush
this is the one game where you want the
Seahawks to run yeah exactly because
that's a weakness run then use
play-action set up the pass I want them
to use a lot of play-action and you know
what would be great you know hopefully
the Seahawks are looking at these
numbers they're looking at these stats
and they can adjust their game plan
based on their opponent and what they're
good at and not good at because it's not
just about going into a room and saying
what do we need to do better and banging
your head against the wall like Freddie
kitchens and go and screw the numbers we
just need to be cleaner we need to I
love this one execute better do not put
your players in a position to execute a
game plan that they do have no chance of
winning and we'll learn about the
Seahawks Seahawks have adapted these
last two weeks they threw the ball a lot
when they needed to and if they come out
against the Niners and they run the ball
a lot I'm all aboard the Seahawks get
bandwagon because they understand it but
Freddie and I'm coming back to kind of
close this one out look at the stats bro
stop stop acting like it's 1975
let's get crack on the phone I have no
pics ready to go
none I'm just gonna ask crack who he
likes we'll see where he's kind of
leaning
what he thinks to the markets and all
that I will be honest and tell you that
you got me very excited about the
Seahawks there your Kirk Cousins stat
hey guys is interesting Oh correct I
like a ding dong how you feeling pal
good man I'm here here in Vegas hanging
out I'm just waiting for you guys to
call just waiting on a friend like the
Rolling Stone said what is a Thursday in
Vegas for crack I mean are you just
scheduled thank you today's a slower
schedule because of there's not a lot of
college basketball on it but however now
there in cross sports college football
college basketball NFL NBA this is the
most crazy time of the year when the
bookmaker has to get a hundred and fifty
Glines right on a Saturday and they just
can't because even though even the
Wednesday Thursday when there's college
basketball so it's so hard for a
bookmaker to get a line right on every
single one of those games and they're
only used to putting up twenty or thirty
so it's a very exciting time for me I've
never thought about that so now that
there are so many sports going on
historically which sport do you think
gets neglected at this time of the year
where there's so many sports on the wall
without without a doubt the sport that I
collected is college basketball I mean
really who's gonna be who's gonna get
these lines right on these especially
the little schools and the smaller
schools like Marshall Bryant
Presbyterian Winthrop's of Kennesaw
State I mean they're just not going to
get them right on those games but they
want to offer blinds on them so they're
gonna have specialists that are going to
attack those smaller conferences and
smaller schools so and and like they
can't get like I said just just Tuesday
they had there's a hundred college
basketball games on the schedule and and
it's just impossible to to for the
originating bookmaker to get every
single line right on on those games
alright so then let's do this crack
which NFL games whether it's line
movements or things you seen have
already caught your attention and if you
have a college basketball game this
weekend that we should be looking at
yeah I think the lines aren't even up on
the college basketball but okay the
college college I'm sorry the NFL
I noticed before the caucus anyway the
Kansas City game warrants bear in the
background right yes here okay so on the
cards here in town on the contest
they're at three and a half and now I'm
seeing the places that are that count at
six
yeah Mahone's I'm sure right exactly
exactly it looks like he might give it a
go and there was uncertainty I guess
when they finalized the West a leg I'm
just telling you oh yeah that's go that
that's gonna be a you can guarantee
people will be using them on the contest
cards okay on the contest we'll be using
the cheese because but now now again
this at this stage halfway through the
season you can do that but at the later
stages when you're playing catch-up
tournament strategy is to actually know
you have to gain a moment gain a game on
them you'd actually pick that over time
yeah you picked a bad line believe it or
not because you're gonna go you're gonna
gain two full games on the people that
are ahead of you so so I noticed that
game and then let's get to uh but let's
get to within one of some of the stuff
that I actually like to that's that's
the way we're going to take this I would
think yeah please Buffalo kind of like
Buffalo a little bit over Cleveland
listen every week they say Cleveland's
gonna Cleveland's gonna rebound this is
a week they've been playing even I have
said it last week I thought they were
gonna step up to the plate and didn't do
it so uh I I think I kind of like
Buffalo with the points there a little
bit I'm looking at that plus three
oh by the way that some of the sharpest
guys and there is sharp guys in contests
believe it or not I listen to a show
this morning that Arizona is his pick
plus four and a half I'm not I haven't
looked at that game yet but you know
these teams score a lot of points though
Tampa Bay has been involved in some bomb
games so that'll be interesting it'll be
a lot of points that opened up six down
to four and a half I'll give you that
what the New York Post is calling the
Battle of the New York dumpster fire
some sir fire battle a giant in the jet
I think that's an interesting game to
look like it's a game where both teams
have been playing so bad
you just don't know who's going to just
wanna more probably giving up on the
season
Paula staying away from it but I'm still
interested in watching it there's a team
that you pick a lot in the contest I
know Warren likes to seem high also like
this team and they took a terrible beat
last week the Colts I thought they
should have beat the Steelers I kind of
liked them laying the point I think
Miami played they're the Super Bowl
already but beating the Jets and I kind
of like Indian that in that contest
thinking they're going to rebound off of
last week and my last pick is Seattle
everyone loves sad faces San Fran really
is like the new America's team I just
think six and a half on the on the on
the contest is a little too high so is
really how about well this wholeness
podcast comes out Friday is there any
lines for college basketball games on
Friday that you've already circled we've
already not okay no no I was really
hoping you were telling me Fordham +20
was a lock yeah some of those week
schools a matter of fact I may be
sharing that now that I know you're
interested though I may be personally
texting you some steals for the
throughout the season oh yes please feed
that degenerate soul of mine crack
you're the man I I honestly I like your
Seattle pick I think I'm leaning that
way a lot of these lines it stinks when
you got like four plus double-digit
lines but I need to sit down I have I
haven't I just didn't want to I wanted
to wait a lot of stuffs come on yeah
wait yes
all right crack I love you pal as always
download the crack winds app check it
out it gives that pick a week and now
that college basketball's out there
this is cracks time to shine it really
is he said it when you guys were here
the first time NFL's cool but I'd rather
play with college basketball MLB and
WNBA so the value for crack really is
this college basketball because he
really is able to go that's great if
everybody wants to talk about North
Carolina Notre Dame but there's a
Winthrop Southeast Missouri State game
that you're not paying attention to and
you're
lines way off do you get into college
basketball at all your college football
and NFL
yeah but primarily the NFL like once
that once the Super Bowl ends and it's
like heyday for college basketball
everybody started March Madness I start
researching and writing my book and I'm
talking to teams and I'm going to the
combine and I'm you know conducting
media and you're explaining the team's
what they've been doing wrong and what
they could do better right and I'm
showing them why I'm actually more
excited for their upcoming season than
they might even be brothers of XY and Z
and things that so I get into I'm NFL
year-round and that's that's what people
that's what the best guys are the best
guys are total specialists so they can
spot the southeast Missouri state line
is off and they know more about that
school than the bookmaker does because
all they care about is college
basketball yeah yeah absolutely you got
it you got a entrust like for a guy like
crack you got any trust what you're
doing to the guys that specialize in
those sports if you try to say oh I'll
I'll do everything there's there's no
chance that you're gonna be good that's
what I do only NFL and NBA coming up
every Tuesday yeah but you know what
they'll say something about that really
quick starting I guess the week of Super
Bowl and going for three or four months
Tuesday nights on TNT it will be the NBA
on TNT and it is going to be Shaq
Candace Parker Dwyane Wade and my dumb
ass and your boy and I don't want to
talk about too much because I will get
emotional but know this that y'all are a
huge part of why I'm able to do this
because when I was able to do the
all-star game you guys were filling up
Twitter and saying [ __ ] ya left go let's
go and when I was doing the match it was
the same thing and do not do not ever
think that I'm gonna get too
disconnected from my journey and and
what you guys have helped me us with 33%
know that you've watt you've witnessed
this whole thing grow
and as this show continues to grow and
what we're doing with its the PlayBook
continues to grow even when I go and do
another sport the fact that you guys are
there on Twitter and going holy [ __ ]
left oh we're [ __ ] doing it it is a
we and so I appreciate if I can do this
bringing the flowers guys goddammit all
right love you guys a lot